lena ich werde das jetzt klarstellen
was
es kommt jetzt etwas plötzlich aber
ich wusste einfach nicht weiter und
führt die nichts besseres als mich zu
beschuldigen
es tut mir leid
wesel ich konnte es nicht sagen
ich bin selbst noch nicht lasst mich
ich bin ich offen
si
möchten sie mich oder zucker kein
schweizer tag zu spät
nein nein die sind gerade erst rein
gegangen guten morgen
lachend das hätte weil sie zu mir nein
zu lukas schmiede hat eine besprechung
ich warte solange
kommt jetzt nur noch getrennt
kommt ihr jetzt nur noch durch sein oder
von glaube hier die termine
canon 2 4 dead man's tor frühstück der
junge arbeitet doch nicht im bau was
sage ich mit einem vormittags großen
die sind ausgefallen weil der kursleiter
krank ist
für die planung der kampagne bleibt also
nicht viel zeit wenn wir gut
zusammenarbeiten kriegen wir das hin
ich habe euch vorschläge in sachen
personal gewählt habe ich gelesen sehr
gut die besten für diesen job sind
natürlich so kurzfristig nicht verfügbar
hey wir sitzen doch die besten das heißt
was die organisation des shootings
angeht könntest du direkt nach dem
meeting anfangen ja selbstverständlich
ich setze mich sofort danke das hobby
unseres protagonisten danach richtet
sich alles musik
musik
geht mitten ins herz
gute idee
der mich die geklaut